bonsoir il ya du nouveau dans la sphère
des écoles juives parallèle les enfants
qui fréquentent ces écoles est qu'ils ne
reçoivent pas l'enseignement obligatoire
sont beaucoup plus nombreux qu'on le
croyait julie avec votre collègue de la
radio émilie dubreuil
alors parce qu'un ado en 2006 septembre
2006 avec julie miville de chêne qui
vous présentait tout un dossier ici sur
les écoles juives illégales subventionné
par québec
nous sommes huit ans plus tard après
plusieurs promesses de règlement
on vous en parle en début d'émission
rien ou à peu près n'est réglé émilie
dubreuil nous présente ce soir le
témoignage révélateur d'un couple de
juifs hassidiques qui a décidé de
quitter la communauté pour permettre à
ses enfants d'aller à l'école et de
s'instruire
comme tous les autres québécois nous
avons le nouveau ministre de l'éducation
avec nous en direct mais d'abord
reportage d'emilie chiffrant en a bravé
bien des tempêtes pour pouvoir venir
chercher ses enfants dans cette école de
côte-des-neiges une école toute simple
pourtant ou ses enfants apprennent les
mathématiques l'histoire la géographie
comme tous les autres enfants du québec
moi je suis
m
ceux vivant
yoann est très en colère contre notre
gouvernement
bien qu'il ait grandi au québec lui n'a
jamais eu cours de mathématiques de
français ou d'anglais seulement une
éducation religieuse ce qui est
contraire à la loi sur l'instruction
publique d'apparaître l'été raconter les
politiciens du québec sont coupables de
mon ignorance et je leur en vue dit il
il y a quatre ans chiffre à yoann ont
fui la communauté toge de boisbriand
justement pour que leurs enfants ne
soient pas ignorants je savais que je
vais tout perdre mais j'ai savez
pourquoi je le faire en 1963 18 familles
de la communauté tosh s'y installent
parce que leur leader le rabbin l'aube
est isolée ses fidèles de ce qu'il
appelle limo vais influence de la ville
cinquante ans plus tard les toges de
boisbriand sont 3000
ma mère est là onze enfants et moi je
pense et j'avais je vais je vais avoir
plus parce que c'est quand même
compétition c'est le seul valeur des
dden d'une femme dont la communauté
c'est d'avoir beaucoup des soldats pour
dire ce chiffre à ewan se sont mariés à
l'âge de 18 ans malgré le fait que leur
union soit le résultat d'un mariage
arrangé le couple s'aime
ils ont quatre enfants mais peu à peu le
doute s'est installé le constat s'est
imposé la seule option quitter mon mari
et moi on a décidé que c'est très
important pour les enfants d'avoir une
bonne éducation
là bas il ya seulement une école et
c'est pas vraiment et l'école
toutes les semaines il ya un différend
portion de vivre qu'en pratique et se
fait tout conte fait toute la journée
il n'y a pas du sport c'est pas une
stimulation pour les pauvres pour le
savoir c'est vraiment une prison
pourtant la loi est claire tous les
enfants ont le droit d'être scolarisés
au québec en vertu d'un régime
pédagogique établi par le ministère de
l'éducation
or pour les toges le régime pédagogique
québécois c'est non merci
dans mon communauté c'est prêt
c'est très grave qu'on a une éducation
c'est pour ça que l'on garde les enfants
très très ignorants et moi j'étais très
contre l'éducation parce que j'ai
vraiment croyez que c'est que dieu il
n'aime pas ça et c'est tout quand il
décide de partir de boisbriand la petite
famille ne parle que le yiddish chiffre
à d'ailleurs appuyé le français dans un
centre pour immigrants de côte des
neiges
les guides itx est aussi une tactique
pour être très une coupe du monde comme
ça les enfants et n'a non pas des
d'accès à d autres informations
la situation chez les tâches n'est pas
unique à outremont et dans le mile end
les sat mar et les sites verts résistent
toujours à l'enseignement laïc et du que
la majorité de leurs enfants dans
l'illégalité
pourtant depuis des années de nombreux
policiers se sont engagés à régler la
question
on souhaite toujours que les enfants
soient scolarisés pour respecter la loi
ça serait que nos matières obligatoires
sont enseignés dans ces écoles au
ministère de l'éducation on refuse de
commenter le dossier
because of politics c'est à cause de la
politique de l'argent et de la commodité
combiné
il y aura un attribut l'inaction du
gouvernement québécois dans cette
délicate question à la peur à la peur
qu'on taxe le gouvernement d' antisémite
s'il sévices et naturel du riche aux
jeunes mais l'antisémitisme d'après moi
c'est de ne pas aider les enfants juifs
batt o'keeffe joe johnston depuis
quelques années de plus en plus de
jeunes hassidique décident de quitter
leur communauté sur des forums de
discussion certains ex évoque l'idée
d'intenter des recours collectifs pour
avoir été privé d'éducation
c'est le cas en israël et dans l'état
new york car être privés d'éducation
selon c'est aussi être privés de la
liberté de choisir son destin
l'éducation c'est senna clés qu'on n'a
pas d'informations on est vraiment
couper les mains c'est vraiment très
très divisée
malgré les sacrifices immenses que ses
parents ont fait en immigrant à quelques
kilomètres mais à des années lumière de
chez eux
il ne regrette rien car le chemin de
l'école c'est surtout celui de la
liberté
émilie dubreuil ce qui est frappant dans
votre reportage cette année c'est que la
critique vient de l'intérieur une
famille de juifs hassidiques il décide
de partir hors on le disait le problème
n'est pas nouveau
combien y at il de ces écoles juives
orthodoxes et les galets seconde est une
idée c'est difficile à établir un
patrice parce que comme elles sont
illégales elles sont clandestines à
londres on ne sait pas où elles elles
sont mais la mathématique on peut faire
ce qu'il ya au moins une dizaine
d'écoles illégale dans les communautés
hassidiques du québec il ya cinq grands
groupes hassidique du québec 2 dans
lesquels on a assez régler la question
cette occasion des permis pour les
garçons comme pour les filles dans
côte-des-neiges notamment et dans le
mile end dans outremont et vous l'avez
vu à boisbriand
la situation est plus complexe ces trois
communautés qui reste dans ses légions
résiste à l'enseignement laïc et on
estime qu'il ya donc une dizaine
d'écoles illégale au moins une dizaine
d'écoles illégale et si on estime qu'il
ya à peu près 12 mai la cité au québec
et que ces communautés leur représentent
la moitié des aspects qu'on peut se
tient au moins quelques centaines
d'enfants voire des milliers d'enfants
qui sont toujours privés de
scolarisation au québec et ça c'est
toujours illégal émilie dubreuil merci
pour ce dossier avec nous je le disais
en direct yves bolduc vous hérité de ce
dossier monsieur beaulieu qui est pas
nouveau on vient de le voir on vient de
voir vos prédécesseurs prédécesseur
pardon qui est un art disait on va
régler la question ce n'est toujours pas
réglée allez vous retirer oui ou non des
subventions à ces écoles qui ne
respectent pas les normes du ministère
l'éducation
d'abord c'est un excellent reportage est
un reportage qui est très troublant
parce que la première préoccupation ce
sont ces élèves qui réussissent pas à
voir la scolarisation des c'est ça qui
reçoivent pas l'enseignement qui est qui
est requis
la réponse on va le regarder rapidement
parce que je demande à avoir une réunion
urgente sur ce qui se passe dans ce
dossier dont entre autres avec le
ministère et également avec d autres
partenaires on part de la direction de
la protection de la jeunesse sont pas du
ministère de la justice
je vais faire le point très rapidement
je suis très content a que quatre à bord
ce dossier là que je l'est en début de
mandat parce que ça va me laisser de la
table et de façon très rapide d'agir
mais comme moi c'est comme vous quand je
vous disais c'est inacceptable que ces
enfants l'un d'entre eux reçoivent pas
la scolarité nécessaire une de vos
prédécesseurs à michelle courchesne
disait moi je vais y aller je vais
mettre fin à ces subventions parce que
comprendre que des écoles vraiment
clandestine qui ne reçoit pas de
subventions c'est un problème qui est à
voir plus aiguë mais il ya des écoles
qui ont un permis du ministère
l'éducation qui reçoivent donc des fonds
publics et en échange à 5-6 ans ils
avaient dit on va donner un corpus on va
donner de l'éducation jeunes ce qui
n'est pas arrivé dans les faits deux
petites questions là-dessus combien sont
combien d'écoles selon ce que vos
fonctionnaires vous dise et qu'on dira
d'inspecteurs pour aller voir dans ces
écoles je pas de réponse ce soir le choc
fois voulait donner plus tard mais je
peux vous dire quelque chose c'est
inacceptable que ce soit des écoles
clandestines dans l'équipe on a
subventionné pas mais que les enfants
reçoivent pas les services ou des écoles
qui reçoivent des subventions mais qui
donne ne donne pas aussi les services
dans les deux cas c'est inacceptable on
va faire le point ce que l'on m'a dit
c'est que c'est difficile de donner de
trouver c'est qui ces écoles quand même
c'est quoi ces écolos c'est comment il
fonctionne mais je peux vous dire que ça
va être maudit aussi prioritaire cette
semaine parce que pour moi je veux faire
le point et également m'assurer que ces
enfants reçoivent la scolarité
nécessaire sa ville l'objectif là c'est
pas toujours de chercher des coupables
mais surtout de régler la situation puis
je sais j'ai vu le reportage que les
plusieurs ministres se sont prononcés
on va trouver la méthode pour savoir où
ça se produit qui sont les enfants qui
et comment on peut faire pour corriger
la situation et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vous disiez s'ils
ne donnent pas les services associés
devrait pas de support sur les plus
importants même s'ils ont peu de
subventions ses enfants ont le droit à
la scolarisation des séries donc vous
êtes bret yves bolduc vous arrivez à ce
ministère la de dire moi je suis prêt à
aller jusqu'à retirer les subventions
très clairement la voulait dit ce soir
du malpas dans cette année n'en a
absolument pas mais c'est plus important
que les subventions
il faut que la situation soit corrigée
comme vous le disais c'est une école
légal qui n'a pas de subventions mais
que l'enfant ne soit pas les services ça
aussi c'est grave parce que ces gens là
ont le droit à ses services et vous avez
vu il ya des gens qui sont sortis de la
communauté justement parce que leurs
enfants vont pas la scolarisation et
qu'eux-mêmes n'ont pas reçu ce avant ce
sont des gens qui devient
dysfonctionnelle
c'est un droit au québec il existe une
loi les gens l'obligation de respecter
la loi et c'est certain qu'on va en fait
des reportages avait peut-être trouvé un
moment donné quand on connaît on connaît
même pas mais quand on les voit on va
agir mais rapidement l'on compare le
point mais parce que c'était jusqu'ici
la théorie des petits ponts on disait
dans les officines gouvernementales ça
fait 50 ans au québec qu'on laisse aller
ça on ne peut pas du jour au lendemain
être sévère est ce que je comprends que
là vous êtes à ses enfants sont nés au
québec ce sont des québécois et ils ont
le droit d'avoir une éducation
québécoise absolument plus récemment la
communauté lève tard qu'il ya des
problèmes qui était différent mais c'est
la même problématique d'abord aussi
quand ils peuvent pas recevoir les
connaissances nécessaires qui ont pas
l'instruction nécessaire il existe une
loi au québec les gens doivent le
respecter
il ya des mécanismes jeu même dit aux
gens s'ils ont des problèmes au niveau
de la loi
dites-moi l'ofppt on va regarder comment
faire pour la modifier c'est un droit et
ce droit doit être respecté
très bien alors vous vous donnez combien
de temps à monsieur bolduc interminable
l'ours a fait ce jour que je suis un
poisson proche et relancer quelques
semaines ne pas avoir l'occasion de se
reparler parce que je pense est une
situation qui va être surveillé mais je
peux vous dire on n'est pas étonné les
passer mais je vais faire mon grand
possible pour qu au cours des prochaines
semaines
on a eu une attitude soit correcte avec
ces gens là mais un incontournable
l'instruction doit être disponible pour
tous les enfants pour qu'ils réussissent
pour tous les enfants du québec qu'ils
ont fait du n'importe quel milieu
il va de nouveau me laisse d'éducation
merci d'avoir été avec nous on va suivre
ce dossier là avec attention merci
beaucoup
ça fait plaisir à la prochaine au revoir
nous adressent commentaires suggestions
gène y aura beaucoup de commentaires on
vous lit avec beaucoup d'attention comme
toujours